1717h55. Au revoir.
BoBonsoir à vous.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Vous m'entendez bien?
- - Oui.
- - Ça va bien. Je voulais vous
didire un petit mot, je sais que
c'c'était pas prévu, mais comme
c'c'est un gel quand même complt
dedes armes d epoing, est-ce que
leles mères de ce pays qui disat
ququ'on n'avait pas géré cela àa
pipièce, donnez-nous des règlesu
jejeu clair, est-ce que pour les
ararmes, Jonathan Trudeau est-ce
quque Monsieur Trudeau vient de
dodonner ce que les provinces et
leles villes voulaient?
- - Pas exactement parce que j'i
l'l'impression qu'il y avait
dadavantage une volonté d'avoir
unune interdiction complète. Mas
jeje pense qu'il y a là un bon
dédébut, assurément mieux que ce
ququi avait été présenté il y a
dedeux ans où on voulait mettree
sisinge sur les épaules, la
reresponsabilité sur les épaules
dedes municipalités et que chacn
esest une législation, des règls
didifférentes. À première vue ça
sesemblait bien. J'aime aussi le
fafait que ce soit un bouquet de
memesures commandées. Ce concept
dede drapeau rouge aussi pour ds
pepersonnes qui représentent un
ririsque pour elle-même ou pour
auautrui de suspendre les permis
dede port d'armes pour des
pepersonnes qui sont coupables e
haharcèlement ou des choses come
cecela. Donc, il faudra analyser
totous les détails. Le projet de
loloi, la personne n'a pu le
coconsulter. Les journalistes ot
coconsultés une heure après la
coconférence de presse. C'est
paparticulier. J'ai hâte d'avoir
leles réactions mais à première
vuvue ça me semble bien.
- - Vous avez raison. Le
cocommuniqué, j'entrais ici pisn
vevenait d'avoir le communiqué.
EÉmilie, Nicolas, un petit mot
cecela?
- - C'est sûr que ce qui avait
sesemblé comme information avant
lala conférence, c'était qu'il
avavait donné la permission aux
prprovinces s d'interdire les as
dede poing, et s'était critiquée
totoutes parts parce que c'est e
QuQuébec et par exemple bannissz
ararmes que le Nouveau-Brunswick
lele fait pas, c'est très facile
dede conduire d'une province à
l'l'autre il n'y a pas de poste
ininter frontalier. C'était ça a
crcrainte qu'il y avait. Ceci d,
avavec la mesure qui est en ce
momoment qui sera remplacé, ça e
fafait rien pour enlever les ars
ququi sont présentement en
cicirculation légale de la
cicirculation. Donc, ça répond s
auaux besoins qui avaient été
énénoncés par les mères. Même
chchose pour les mesures de
drdrapeau rouge. Une critique,
c'c'était que ça mettait
esessentiellement la
reresponsabilité sur les victims
popotentielles ou les victimes
réréelles, d'aller en justice de
ququ'une personne peut être
dadangereusement demandée que ce
sosoit la justesse et la police
ququi fasse ses demandes plutôt
quque la victime elle-même. Don,
cecette critique rest Walley :
pupuis je pense qu'en terminant,
ilil faut vraiment dire que la
grgrande majorité des armes à fu
ququi sont en circulation à
MoMontréal qui sont utilisés das
leles crèmes, une grande partie
sosont déjà les armes illégales
ququi viennent des États-Unis.
C'C'est vraiment les mesures sur
lele renforcement des frontières
pepetits fait une grosse
didifférence sur les armes à fex
réréels - circule à Montréal. Me
chchose pour les armes à feu qui
sosont des armes à feu sans numo
dede série qu'on a de la
didifficulté à voir d'où elles
prproviennent. Ça ne fait pas ue
grgrosse différence sur ces homs
ararmés connaît des mesures pour
cecela au niveau des frontières.
- - Mais si je recule de plusies
mmètres, voilà, c'est quand même
auau Texas, à 18 ans, il est alé
lolors de son anniversaire
s's'acheter une arme de montagee
lala gomme, cela envoie quand me
unun signal qu'à chaque fois que
leles pièces législatives que
c'c'est pas des joujoux, c'est s
ququelque chose que l'on doit
fafacilement obtenir.
- - Non. Ça envoie un message ft
enen même temps, on voit que c't
pépénible d'envoyer un télé
memessage parce que regarder,
poposition des libéraux en 2020t
202021 et 2022, ils ont reculé r
lala promesse il y a un an.
TeTellement que le collectif avt
didit : jetez votre projet de li
auaux poubelles. Ils ont changé
leleur position à la campagne
élélectorale. Et les arrive avec
leles quelque chose de
cocomplètement inédit, offrir ue
coconférence de presse avant
coconduise le projet de loi. Je
susuis un peu sur mes gardes qut
àà mes commentaires parce que on
a a procédé dans l'ordre invers.
QuQuand un gouvernement est fiée
soson projet, il essaie pas de e
cacacher et d'empêcher les
jojournalistes de le lire avante
poposer la question.
- - C'est normal. Rester sur vos
gagardes. On ne peut pas parlerà
nonotre journaliste pour le
momoment. Grosse fin de semaine
popolitique. Je vous fais entene
MoMonsieur Legault, il est dit e
lele Québec va devenir la
LoLouisiane.
ApAprès la pause, c'est le panel
- - Je suis convaincu qu'une
mamajorité des Québécois
sosont d'accord pour que
lele gouvernement fédéral
nonous transfère ses pouvoirs
auau gouvernement du Québec.
C'C'est pour ça que je demande,
auaux prochaines élections,
unun mandat fort pour aller
nénégocier ça avec le gouvernemt
féfédéral. C'est une question
dede survie pour notre nation!
S Si on continue d'avoir cette
papartie de l'immigration choise
papar Ottawa qui accepte la moié
dedes immigrants qui parlent pas
frfrançais, bien là, ça peut
dedevenir une question de temps
avavant qu'on devienne une
LoLouisiane. Donc, il faut
exexpliquer ça aux Québécois.
CÇa, c'est la première étape.
- - Est-ce qu'on va expliquer
sosouvent... différentes
cacatégories dans les migration.
CeCe sont des chiffres de 2021.
C'C'est le Québec jusqu'à 25 000
etet regroupements familial este
1111 000 à 11 400 pour cette
anannée. Réfugié, c'est ce que e
CaCanada contrôle aussi. Deux
cacatégories.
AlAlors, si on isole le
reregroupement familial, c'était
1212 000, la moitié ne parle pas
ananglais, et cet e-mail. Si on
enenlève les enfants, selon des
cacalculs, il en reste 2000. Es-
cece que le regroupement familil
vava sauver le Québec? Jonathan?
- - Ces quelques milliers nous
mmèneraient directement au bord
dudu précipice ce qui voudrait
didire que déjà la situation est
crcritique. La personne va dire
quque tout va bien au niveau du
frfrançais parce que clairementà
MoMontréal. C'est important que
l'l'on s'y attarde. J'ai
l'l'impression que François
LeLegault en fin de semaine se
chchercher un message à sortir e
cece congrès. Les gens avaient é
ququ'on regarde les proposition,
alalors qu'on parle d'inflation,
lele coût de la vie, etc. Ça
sesemblait mince au niveau du
cocontenu. Il est chargé un
memessage fort pour sortir de ce
cocongrès, j'ai l'impression qul
a a finalement été un peu trop
fofort parce que je sentais qu'n
vovoulait un peu aller vers
l'l'arrière. Parce que
l'l'immigration est un enjeu
imimportant, mais de là à penser
quque ça va être l'enjeu de la
prprochaine campagne électorale,
ininquiétez-vous pas, on va parr
d'd'autres priorités du coût dea
vivie, inflation, etc. Il voulat
unun message fort. Il a peut-ête
étété un peu trop fort :
- - Il a lancé le ballon trop
loloin. Quelques lignes préparés
mamais il en a pris une et il a
mamagnfiée de sorte que comme tp
s's'être pas assez.?
- - Et laisser échapper avec cet
exexemple qui est pour le moins
ététonnant. Faut il rappelait
ququ'elle n'a jamais plus que la
teterre des habitants de la
LoLouisiane qui par les Français
ququi n'avaient pas de là pour
prprotéger les Français. Je pene
papas que c'était le meilleur
exexemple. Mais c'était déjà
évévoqué en anglais. Donc c'est
papas la première fois. Et moi,e
ququi m'étonne, c'est qu'elle ae
cocorde autant d'importance au
niniveau du regroupement famili.
VoVous l'avez dit, c'est 10 000
pepersonnes et la moitié d'entre
elelle ne parle pas français. Ms
àà leur arrivée. Le regroupement
fafamilial, ce sont les enfantst
leles conjoints des nouveaux
ararrivants. Les enfants vont
dedevoir aller à l'école en
frfrançais. Donc, peut-être qu's
vovont parler français assez
rarapidement par la suite. Et
c'c'est une question presque de
didignité. Si on fait venir
ququelqu'un, on va pas lui
dedemander de se couper de sa
fafamille comme premier geste pr
l'l'intégrer dans la société. Ce
seserait, comment dire, pas très
élélégant. Ça m'étonne qu'on
acaccorde autant d'importance sr
cecet aspect. Et je note aussi a
sysymétrie entre la menace selon
MoMonsieur Legauault, la surviee
l'l'animation, rien de moins et
leles moyens qu'il est prêt à
prprendre. Il est dit qu'il veut
avavoir un mandat phare. Il a dà
unun mandat phare. Tout ce qu'il
rereste dans son coffre à outil,
c'c'est d'aller chercher un
réréférendum est sectorielle mas
çaça l'intéresse pas parce que n
réréférendum, des Québécois n'en
veveulent pas et ont peur de ce
momot. Donc c'est un peu étrang.
BeBeaucoup de décapage à travers
lele discours politique à faire
cecette fin de semaine.
- - Émilie, première impression
faface a cette déclaration de
MoMonsieur Legault?
- - D'abord je sais pas s'il y a
dedes francophones de la Louisie
ququi nous écoute, mais j'espère
ququ'il va envoyer les lettres
dadans les journaux québécois ds
leles prochains jours. Je pense
quque si on est pour utiliser la
LoLouisiane comme métaphore, il
fafaudrait des résidents de la
LoLouisiane qui nous donne à les
gegestes.
C'C'est l'ignorance de la réalié
llà-bas. Ceci étend dit, je peux
jujuste réitérer ce qui a été dt
pupuis rajouter que lorsque
ququelqu'un comme premier minise
didit que les immigrants
papar Ottawa menacent l'existene
dede l'animation québécoise, ça
veveut dire que un paquet de
QuQuébécois originaires de
l'l'immigration qui écoute cela,
pupuisqu'ils sont pas rassurés u
totout par les propos que le
prpremier ministre bien adhéré,
c'c'est leurs enfants ou ceux qi
écécoutent cela. C'est comme si
nonos familles, non pas revenue
icici par ramifications
fafamiliales, c'est une menace.
C'C'est important d'avoir
l'l'analyse de ce qui se passe,e
cece qui est dit et puis des
coconséquences politiques mais
auaussi de simplement prendre le
tetemps de quelqu'un premier
miministre dit des choses comme
cecela, il y a des gens qui sont
isissus de ces groupes.
JeJe sais pas si franchement, le
prpremier ministre compte sur lr
vovote éventuel mais c'est sur e
s's'il y en avait qui pourrait
êêtre tenté de voter pour lui,
c'c'est sur que c'est pas
exexactement vendeur.
- - On est dans la stratégie. On
vovoulait peut-être des fois
vovouloir trop simplifier certas
memessages.
C'C'est ce que ça donne d'avoir
unune pensée trop stratégique,
JoJonathan.
- - C'était en phase avec le
memessage de la fin de semaine.
J'J'étais là ce week-end et
enenvoyait que tout tournait
auautour du concept de la fierté
dudu nationalisme. Allez la
coconférence faite par le minise
dede l'agriculture, sur la fier,
onon se rend compte que pour la
CACAQ, Stéphane fierté d'être
cacaquiste, c'est être fié d'ête
ququébécois. Cette idée est en
coconfrontation avec le fédéral
sosont des questions identitairs
etet des questions d'immigratio.
C'C'est venu en phase avec toute
rereste du discours du congrès
mamais je pense que sur cette
nonote, on a poussé un peu trop
loloin.
- - Très bien. Paul, d'ailleurs,
onon a parlé la semaine dernièr,
dadans la déclaration du fédéral
susur la loi 96, ils sont
atattentifs et vont voir que pe-
êêtre ils feront ceci ou cela.
C'C'est la même réaction, Monsir
LeLegault se nourrit de cela
auaussi.
- - Oui. Les fédéral se nourrite
cecela aussi. Il faut pas croire
ququ'il y a seulement Monsieur
LeLegault qui politise ses enjex
popour en faire un gain partisa.
ReRegardez la réaction du minise
dede la justice. Il va faire une
dédéclaration sur la loi 21 pour
didire qu'elle voudrait plaidern
cocour suprême pour un
reresserrement encadrement de la
didisposition des dégradations.
C'C'est pas banal parce que ça
éqéquivaut à revoir les conditis
mmêmes du rapatriement de la
coconstitution. Il faut rappeler
quque huit provinces étaient
cocontre. Cette ont été convainu
dede signer la constitution à
cacause de cette disposition
d'd'dérogations à Québec n'a pas
sisigné. L'ministre de la justie
etet banaliser tout cela et
anannonce qu'il veut revenir sur
cece compromis historique et il
fafait avant même que la cause a
étété entendue devant la cour
d'd'appel. Peu importe ce qu'on
pepense, qu'on soit d'accord ou
nonon, ça reste qu'il y avait ue
ststratégie partisane très forte
llà-dedans donc les batailles
sosont toujours meilleures quand
dedeux personnes veulent se bate
etet c'est le cas ici.
- - Exactement. On a l'impressin
quque les fédéral ne se privera
papas de cette bataille non plu.
MoMonsieur Trudeau n'a plus rieà
peperdre. Il est assuré de
cocontinuer pendant tous les
tetermes de son mandat grâce au
NPNPD. Et là, c'est comme s'il
ététait décomplexé. Il y a des
babatailles que je veux mener
auaussi au Québec. On sent un
dudurcissement des deux côtés.
- - On sent un durcissement.
BeBeaucoup a été dits sur la
poposition du fédéral dans la li
2121 et 96. C'est sûr que le fat
quque le gouvernement fédéral
veveuille avoir son mot à dire
dadans ce dossier, ça va encore
susupprimer, c'est pas du tout y
esest légitime. La façon dont ce
cocommuniqué qui peut aller
enensuite et d'François Legault,
ququi veut prétendre que tout ca
esest un affrontement Québec est
cocontre le Canada alors que pln
dede gens au Québec son
auautocritique de ses lois. Le
ththéâtre de l'affrontement se
jojoue effectivement à deux
bebeaucoup de gens au Canada
ananglais dans les autres
prprovinces qui sont très contes
ququand le gouvernement fédéral
n'n'y va pas avec les gants blas
susur la critique de ses lois pr
dedes raisons qui n'ont rien à
vovoir avec le Québec mais plus
avavec le sentiment que eux
veveulent un gouvernement fédérl
àà faire. Beaucoup de
gégéopolitique. Pendant que ça e
jojoue, les minorités sont
totouchées par ces lois qui sont
dedes balles de ping-pong.
- - Au travers tout cela, nous
ououblions pas qu'il y a des
rerelations humaines. Pas d'amor
peperdu entre Justin Trudeau et
FrFrançois Legault. François
LeLegault est même en déficit pr
rarapport à Justin Trudeau. On e
dedes épisodes de la dernière
cacampagne électorale. Impolitee
l'l'expérience qui m'a déjà
inindiqué particulièrement en
popolitique la tendance est un
plplat qui se mange froid. On na
papas fini d'avoir Justin Trudeu
dodonné, de vouloir un peu agir.
- - en même temps, ça peut aider
auaussi Monsieur Legault beaucop
dodonc tout cela... certains
rrêvent un autre référendum. Mas
c'c'est une autre chose un consl
nanational de Québec solidaire.n
vava écouter un extrait. Des
mimilitants n'ont pas aimé que
QuQuébec solidaire vote pour la
loloi 96. On n'écoute pas
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - C'est un défi de longue date
àà Québec solidaire, de concilir
nonotre fonctionnement
dédémocratique et les exigences
dudu Parlement. Je pense que nos
mimilitants, militantes font ler
trtravail d'exprimer leur opini.
IlIls nous disent ce qu'ils
pepensent de nos décisions, puis
c'c'est ça, un parti démocratiq,
c'c'est ça, un parti transparen.
- - Tour de table. Émilie?
CeCertains militants n'ont pas
aiaimé la pluie du parti à la li
9696.
- - Québec solidaire cette
crcritique de l'ensemble de
memesures dans la loi 96 dans la
ququestion des six mois pour acs
auaux services en français pour
leles immigrants et la façon dot
çaça touche les communautés
auautochtones. Ils ont voté pour
papareil parce qu'on est un
rerenforcement de la loi 101 sur
cecertains autres aspects. Alors
quque par exemple les Parti
ququébécois n'a pas jugé utile e
vovoter pour le projet de loi me
sisi le Parti québécois n'est ps
cocontre le renforcement de la i
10101. Québec solidaire s'est ms
dadans une position très bizarre
ouoù il pouvait très bien dire
ququ'il était pour certain
rerenforcement de la loi 101, ss
vovoter pour. La loi répartit ls
totoutes façons. Ils vont passer
leles prochains mois a essayé de
réréparer les pots cassés avec s
paparties. C'est vraiment pas
brbrillant je trouve l'avoir fat
cecela. Tu as besoin de militans
dadans la prochaine campagne
élélectorale.
- - Jonathan, il se disait que
l'l'inverse aurait été pire envs
d'd'autres. Qu'en pensez-vous?
- - J'ai l'impression que peu
imimporte, il aurait été perdan.
C'C'est très difficile d'essayer
dede gérer ce parti. Je trouve e
lala position de Québec solidaie
àà l'Assemblée nationale était
reresponsable, acétate de
rereconnaître qu'il a de bons
asaspects et de moins bons et ls
enengager à les modifier
évéventuellement. Mais ne pas
lalaisser tous les terres libreà
lala claque et de ce qu'il y a e
nonous qui voulions concrètement
rarapidement apporter des
chchangements pour solidifier la
loloi 101. Malheureusement ça
sesemble plutôt difficile devant
soson parti pour Gabriel Nadeau
DuDubois et je pense qu'on n'a s
fifini d'avoir ce genre de
sisituation se répéter.
- - Paul, je pense au Parti
ququébécois. On va écouter un
exextrait.
IlIl est dit qu'on reste debout
imimporte le contexte.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chchef, Parti québécois
- - Peu importe ce que vous dit
lala CAQ, l'indépendance
dudu Québec, elle est nécessaire
etet elle est urgente. Et dans
cece contexte-là, notre message
popour vous, c'est : la CAQ
n'n'a pas besoin de votre vote,
mamais l'indépendance du Québec,
elelle, oui.
- - C'était samedi. Paul, quandl
vovous?
- - Quand les Parti québécois
prproposait pas de référendum en
leleur disait que vous cachez
vovotre option. Ils en proposent
unun et les Québécois n'en veult
papas. On peut pas les critiquer
d'd'une chose et de son contrai.
J'J'ai l'impression que pour les
PaParti québécois, le défi est e
tetenir bon de survivre à la
prprochaine élection parce que
pepeut-être que François Legault
vava bientôt devenir un allié
obobjectif parce que c'est les
enengagé dans des débats dans ls
cocombats avec le fédéral, sur a
loloi 21, affrontement sur la li
9696, l'immigration, peut-être e
leles Parti québécois continuent
dede dire que si vous revendiqu,
pepeut-être que vous devriez
rerevenir au bercail. Ils ont
acactualisé le budget de
l'l'indépendance de François
LeLegault. Je sais pas s'il le
sisignerait encore.
- - Jonathan.
- - Ce que je constate c'est que
leles Parti québécois fait l'apl
auau vote stratégique. On parle
d'd'indépendance merci beaucoupe
didire de ne pas voter pour
FrFrançois Legault. On où on a
bebesoin de votre vote et pas l'
CACAQ. La situation est critiqu.
- - Survivrait.
- - Effectivement. Pour les Pari
ququébécois